à roissy les forces de l'ordre viennent
d'évacuer la zone de fret en raison
d'une action menée depuis mardi matin
par plusieurs centaines de salariés
d'air france 3 concorde de la compagnie
et est immobilisé depuis cet après midi
ce coup de force s'est produit il ya à
peine deux heures les eaux lamberton on
comptait plus de pole ici ce soir à
roissy que de grévistes
depuis cet après midi une centaine de
salariés d'air france de la division
matériel bloqué trois concorde dont
celui que doit prendre demain françois
mitterrand pour se rendre au yémen des
grévistes sans illusions ce soir à 21h
le tribunal de bobigny ordonne la levée
des piquets de grève peu de temps après
les forces de l'ordre interviennent le
blocus des concorde est terminée
c'est par solidarité avec leurs
collègues du fret que les salariés de la
division matériel se sont mis en grève
depuis mardi
le fret d'air france est paralysée 8
cargos sont bloqués à roissy
motif les salariés refusent les
nouvelles suppressions d'emplois
annoncées par la direction
il refuse aussi qu'on réduise leur prime
ce soir les piquets sont levés mais la
grève continue jusqu'à au moins demain
après midi à l'issue de la rencontre
entre les syndicats et la direction
le